it's now exactly seven weeks since
lockdown measures were introduced the
extent to which you have stopped to
these rules often at great personal
sacrifice has been truly remarkable so I
want to start with a heartfelt thank-you
by staying at home you have saved lights
seven weeks ago the virus was spreading
out of control today it is in retreat
those who work in our NHS have been
under immense pressure and they have
responded magnificently but the Health
Service has not been overwhelmed in the
way we feared it would be in the last
four weeks the number of covert 19
patients in intensive care has fallen by
almost two-thirds and last week we saw
the most welcomed sign of all for the
first time since the epidemic started
the number of deaths registered in a
single week fail so the progress is real
and it is down to you but our progress
is still fragile if we ease up too soon
the virus could run out of control again
that would mean more people dying and
all of us staying in lockdown much
longer there will of course be risks
whenever we start to ease the lockdown
but my judgment right now is that the
risk is still too great too many people
are still dying and the situation in
care homes despite the extraordinary
dedication of our care workers remains a
serious concern and the important are
number the rate at which the virus
reproduces is still uncomfortably close
to one if it exceeds one the virus could
rapidly take off again that's why the
Scottish Government is exercising such
care and caution we announced one change
to the rules yesterday if you want to
exercise outdoors more than once a day
you can no do so but otherwise we are
asking you to stick with lockdown for a
bit longer so that we can consolidate
our progress not jeopardize it except
for essential work that can't be done at
home going out for food and medicine or
for exercise please continue to stay at
home when you do go outside please stay
two metres from other people and don't
meet up with people from other
households please wear a face covered
if you are in a shop or in public
transport and wash your hands thoroughly
and regularly these measures are
essential for now but we know they cause
harm of their own so we will not keep
them in place for longer than necessary
as the infection rate continues to fall
we will gradually relaxed the
restrictions and we're already making
preparations for that we're working with
businesses to produce guidance on safe
workplaces we're working on the change
is needed on public transport and we're
talking to teachers and parents about
how and when schools can safely return
we're doing all of that carefully
because it is vital that when we do ask
you to return to work or to school you
have clarity about what we are asking
you to do and also confidence that it is
safe we're also expanding our ability to
test people for covered 19 and trace
those they've been in contact with that
will be important to control new
outbreaks on all of this I will keep you
informed every step of the way I want to
make sure that as we take each step on
the path to recovery the ground beneath
us is as solid as possible but I will
not keep these restrictions in place
longer than necessary
as far as Minister I know the impact
this has on all of you and as a citizen
I miss my family too but I won't risk
unnecessary deaths by acting rashly or
prematurely so I am asking you please
for the moment to continue to do what
you have been doing so responsibly I
also want to say a special thank you to
children not being at school or seeing
your friends or hugging your
grandparents is really tough but you
have handled it brilliantly I'm so proud
of all of you for all of us I know it's
getting harder but let's keep supporting
each other even as we stay apart let's
remember what matters most health family
community staying at home no is an
expression of love kindness and
solidarity we're doing it for each other
not just ourselves it is how we protect
each other protect our
chase and save lives and it will also
bring forward that moment when we can
begin a return to normality so once
again my thanks to each and every one of
you